après plusieurs années en couple ouais
j'ai une certaine expérience de la vie
je me rends compte qu'il ya certaines
filles qui sont quand même plus jalouse
que d'autres sauf que maintenant je
connais le responsable de 99% des
embrouilles de couples liés à la
jalousie c'est lui
salut tu fais d'un téléphone voilà c'est
cette connerie et même si tu es un
mixage un mec fidèles ya toujours une
photo un message qui peut être mal
interprété c'est qui c'est une grosse
[ __ ] dégueulasse et vulgaire acquis avec
toi sur la photo bah c'est toi ça ouais
c'est marrant ah ouais c'est vous dire
on dit au coach et à woerth
je crois qu'il ya certains textos qu'il
faut surtout pas recevoir quand tu es en
couple
notamment ce fameux tu fais quoi
messages reçus à deux heures du matin
par un numéro inconnu tu m'expliques
peut-être c'est un pote tu veux faire un
foot à 2 heures du matin je t'écoute
pourquoi il répond pas je préfère un fou
de tous à la fois ya pire je crois que
le truc qui rend le plus hystérique une
meuf au monde c'est quand tu reçois un
texto devant elle mais que tu le lis pas
ça mon gars c'est grave
[Musique]
quand tu n'es pas un message moi je
lirai plus tard facile
bon je parle le livre de poche d'air ça
donne quoi est un truc à cacher tu lis
martin sinon je te quitte blick vous
informe que votre forme avec une photo
de ses seins
je le jure je deviens bouffe
parfois j'ai tellement peur que ma meuf
poule mon portable et trouve des trucs
chelous que j'emporte mon téléphone avec
moi partout dans chacune des pièces de
la maison
bonjour ma douche ou à tout avec ton
iphone bah ouais et ton ipad
bah ouais et ton ordinateur portable
ouais et la box internet
ouais et le câble ethernet ah ouais et
en disque dur externe
bah ouais et ton casque audio bon écoute
quand je vais prendre ma douche j'aime
bien être un petit peu connectés ça pose
problème
génération y bon je sais pas si j'ai la
poisse ou quoi et moi a dit que je tombe
par pur hasard sur une photo un peu
ambigu c'est précisément à cette seconde
que ma meuf débarque c'est le match
aller ça va salut pierre gatz koala aux
jeux sur facebook friend tranquille et
puis photos de paysages je regarde le
sahara la montagne alors de passer une
journée au pas mais tu te filme à égal
en plus comme ça la fout ta gueule je
trouve qu'il a plus reçu ma graisse
comme ça je suis décontracté
est-ce que ça passer une bonne journée
normale pour qu'on parle retour par les
coûts toujours parlé en permanence je
dois parler de tous ces problèmes
peuvent aussi ça j'aime l'info mais je
regarde la forêt moyens il ya des
questions auxquelles j'ai jamais su
répondre un de peur de l'annexé ou de la
rendre jalouse je parle évidemment de ce
genre de questions tu veux dire si j'ai
plus grosse qu'elle la question piège
bon déjà il faut surtout pas être
sincère franchement moi est un peu plus
gros cela ni mitigé pas franchement
c'est pareil je suis aussi grosse que ce
tonneau ouais ni mentir non franchement
tellement grosse tellement grosse en
plus tu mens ni être hésitant ouais ça
dépend non mais en plus tu en profites
pour mater n'ont ni même faire diversion
regarde un hélicoptère ou sa non
magnifie comptes avec ta meuf dans la
rue dans un café tu peux pas regarder
notre fille tu as normal ça va la rendre
jalouse bons amants d'utiliser une
petite technique
pourquoi sur carte sd comme ça tu veux
son numéro la fois technique non pas du
tout
ce que je trouve tellement vulgaire as
well as des gros seins avec un gros
décolleté profond c'est indécent c'est
vrai que ça va un petit peu parce
qu'avoir une peau bien bronzé comme ça
ça va être stylée n'importe quoi
ressasser ce thème pas les filles comme
ça c'est quoi ça mc ça m'a dégoûté
jean-luc me paraît d'ici comme le casse
illico voilà pourquoi il faut toujours
être sincère authentique honnête fidèle
francs est toujours dire la vérité à
celle qu'on aime aux hélicoptères et on
est le copain de fac norman
mon spectacle norman sur scène reprend à
paris au palace à partir du 15 octobre
peut commencer déjà à réserver vos
places en suivant les sortes de petites
flèches qui clignotent sur votre écran
franchement ça va être des mares et j'y
pense toujours ça va être trop débat